an escape killer is finally back behind
bars after avoiding capture for two
weeks brand new images show police
bringing danello cavicante into custody
and authorities just releasing this new
mug shot of him that comes as we learn
more about how the dramatic Manhunt in
Pennsylvania finally ended cavalcante
left battered and bloodied in a stolen
Eagles hoodie after an elite border
patrol group from El Paso known as
bortak teamed up with State Police to
take him down they use thermal
technology to track his movements and
then Unleashed a canine in the morning
to sniff out and subdue the brutal
pillar state police officers revealing
what they believe was the key to his
capture
they were able to move in very quietly
they had the element of surprise
Cabo Conte did not realize he was
surrounded until that had occurred
that did not stop him from trying to
escape he began to crawl through thick
underbrush taking his rifle with him as
he went
one of the Customs and Border control
teams bortak had a dog with them they
released the dog
the community that was locked down for
two weeks they can finally rest easy
local residents saying how relieved they
are that they won't have to worry about
a killer on the loose
I flicked the lights on and off and then
he flipped the lights back and that was
the moment where I my wife was already
on with 9-1-1 but I was like he's
downstairs called 9-1-1 right now so it
was it was a scary Moment The Saga
um of living in Longwood when he's two
miles away very tense very much on edge
how is it sinking in I'm so excited I
feel like crying because I couldn't
actually sleep now at night I've been up
all night every night for the last two
weeks and now that calvacante is back in
custody there's new questions over how
easy it was for him to escape in the
first place and judge the jail says that
there are new protocols there to make
sure security is better this happened
actually not too long ago with another
prisoner they caught him right away but
the amount of resources this took it's a
lot but he's now in custody and will
probably be but for the rest of his life
uh yeah I don't think he's going
anywhere and you know calls to have been
deported are ridiculous I mean when I
was D.A I would have people deported who
were convicted thinking let this country
pay for him instead of us they let him
go and they come back in uh but first
thing I want to say is kudos to uh to
the colonel Bivins this guy was measured
he was focused he was determined he
never lost faith I mean and he had a
huge team to coordinate so
congratulations to him now as it relates
to the prison this is a prison where the
maximum term of incarceration is 24
months so it really is like a county
jail and they're held there until
they're moved to the state prisons but
we've seen a lot of problems in these
County jails or facilities like Rikers
where everyone was asleep when Jesse
Epstein uh Jeffrey Epstein apparently is
thinking of you Jesse yeah yeah
apparently you know supposedly killed
himself look there's got to be a new uh
requirement they've got there's new
technology in place the guy that was on
the Watchtower he got fired but you know
people get comfortable when they're on a
job for 15 18 years and we've got a test
retest and continue to make sure that
they are doing their job correctly but I
think that the biggest story here is not
just the resolution of the people who
were they just said they were tents on
edge they didn't sleep the schools were
closed
this is a guy that we knew had killed
someone he was illegal when he came into
this country we didn't know that he
killed someone in Brazil all right but
every day in this country people are
coming in from other countries about
whom we know nothing we know nothing we
don't know their backgrounds we don't
have their fingerprints even the
attorney general in the State of Florida
had to go to court to get the Biden
Administration to stop releasing
illegals on mass into the interior
without our knowing who they are so how
many more are there from other countries
that's my concern but now that it's all
said and done congratulations we saw
firsthand that law enforcement works
well and works well together and for all
you people who want to defund the police
just talk to the people who were worried
about police not being there when he was
around yeah you want the police at this
point oh I disagree completely with
everything you just said first of all uh
Dana I questioned whether it was a
stolen Eagles hoodie this guy is a
multiple killer Maniac in Philly that's
an Eagles fan so
he was caught he is a jerk he drank all
my Ovaltine and he hugged all the
blankets but I do not get the outcry
over this at all true he's illegal but
America is a Melting Pot and that
includes Killers right it's not like he
voted for Trump Dana you know and I get
it he's a violent reoffender but since
when in the last three years did that
really matter every major city has
released a slew of violent reoffenders
who went on to beat to rape and kill
under the Trojan Horse of prison and
bail reform we were promised that that
would only affect non-violent offenders
and we were lied to and I'm disgusted
disgusted Dana that they sent the evil
police after this guy when clearly
social workers could have handled this
and remember according to the squad
prison is cruel and inhumane punishment
so in a way that escape was just an
accelerated version of early release he
took the initiative and beat the Soros
DA's to the punch and we're punishing
him so to summarize he escaped so what
he's not the criminal he's not the
oppressor the prison is the polices
Society is he was clearly oppressed by
the system I only hope in the next few
months when he declares his new identity
as a woman they better put him in the
prison of his chosen gender and if the
female inmates complain about the
assaults and the rapes they're just
being transphobic
[Laughter]
that was very good I like the part where
they catch him and then they make them
say cheese let's go line up behind them
and take photos that's great so the dog
was on last night and he said exactly
what the judge said if you have a wide
open border you have America's Most
Wanted from the third world piling and
you have no clue who these people are
and then we had John Walsh and America's
Most Wanted and he said that he was
surprised that this task force wasn't
ramped up to bring in Marshals to bring
in the National Guard to bring in
Sharpshooters because at two weeks you
know he's about to kill again so
thankfully they got the guy fetterman
hadn't said a word he was walking around
going about impeachment and this guy
looks like he was probably trying to get
back to Brazil because they don't have
an extradition treaty that is is a long
walk I don't think he was getting on a
flight but I'm glad they caught him
before he got to Delaware because Hunter
probably would have gotten his hands on
him this was a great job by these guys
two weeks and if you know what it's like
in a Manhunt I'm sure you know that
that's like Greg great Barr four years
in college
these guys you don't understand what
they're going for they're sleeping in in
gymnasium floors they're given meals in
a box it's there's bugs out there it is
damp it's terrible and they finally got
them so congrats and actually the a lot
of new technologies that were used
including that thermal imaging but also
people with ring cameras they were able
to catch him so that they were able to
track him a little bit and keep him in
that perimeter yeah I mean there's no
question that entire Community it was
definitely a community effort supporting
law enforcement's ability to catch him
um you know August we saw the highest
number of illegal border crossings ever
uh in this country you couple that with
the Department of Homeland Securities
leaked letters saying hey we get that
the detention facilities are at capacity
so we're encouraging you guys to release
people in the interior to be able to
make room and not go over capacity
President Biden's open border policy is
no different from his
policies domestically to not prosecute
criminals so you're seeing over and over
basically it's an undermining of the
rule of law this President doesn't care
about the Safety and Security of the
American people is unwilling to enforce
even the laws that actually exist to
protect the American people and
ultimately therefore is is de facto
taking the side of criminals human
traffickers uh and and the cartels and
the American people these communities
are the ones who suffer as a result so
glad it's over for all those people
there yes sir yes Billy Eagles Jesse I
know he stole the shirts
seem to fit him very well it well and
then they cut it off and that was some
good TV we watched it this morning all
right everyone and Brian Kilmeade I want
you to do me a favor I want you to click
to subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
page this is the only way that I know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now